il fallait casser le Holland baching et
le président a fait
sacrifice de sa candidature pour casser
le H baching mon action comme président
de la République et d'abord une action
de
protection il faut protéger celles et
ceux qui sont les plus fragiles je pense
que c'est un acte assez courageux 7 ans
à montré qu'un politique est pas
forcément accroché au pouvoir et qui
peut de temps en temps avoir les
oreilles ouvertes objectivement il a été
poussé vers la sortie hein faut faut
quand même pas
rêveranch et que je crois qu'il repart
comme il est arrivé c'est-à-dire par
dépit et peut-être même par hasard
finalement il a été expulsé de
l'élection présidentielle il l'a été par
ses propres amis qui ont tout fait pour
l'empêcher d'être
candidat vous visez quelqu'un en
particulier c'est Manuel Val j'imagine
mais moi je une vise personne je vais
vous annoncer que je ne sais pas si
manuel B va présenté merci merci
dis je soutiendrai le premier ministrequ
j'ai estime et respect mais il n'est pas
encore
candidat on ne sait pas qui de François
Hollande manuel Vals est la lame ou le
manche du couteau qui a déchiré la
gauche manuel Vals a théorisé les
gauches irréconciliables pour ma part je
veux les gauches réconciliés je lance un
appel à Emmanuel Macron à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon rejoignez la primaire de la
gauche
faites en sorte que l'unité se réalise
alors que Jean-Christophe cambadelli
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron à y participer
l'ancien ministre lui répond dans une
interview et ne mâche pas ses mots le
vainqueur de cette primaire de gauche ne
sera pas soutenu par ses concurrents
malheureux cette primaire c'est OK Coral
conclu-t-il on ne peut pas être
président sans avoir de débat sans avoir
de combat il faut s'affronter un petit
peu on n'est pas dans l'univers waté des
haut fonctionnaires désignés par les
politiques grâce à fidèle Castro les
Cubains ont récupéré leur territoire
leur vie leur destin sur son analyse du
castrisme je ne m'y retrouve pas et pour
moi fidè Castro est loin d'être un
parangon de vertu démocratique certains
ne vont pas se se Rabiller à bon compte
au nom des des droits de l'homme alors
qu'on sait que ici quand on demande des
listes des prisonniers politiques on n a
pas bah fournissez-moi des liste de
prisonniers politiques à ce moment-là on
pourra faire quelque chose il y a pas de
limite aux bêtises que les responsables
politiques peuvent dire
plus jamais de leçons de la gauche sur
les droits de l'homme après l'éloge de
Castro par un ministre socialiste rail
le filloniste Thierry Mariani ça me
rappelle une autre déclaration que
cgolen Royal avait faite autrefois pour
présenter la justice chinoise en exemple
pour la justice française combien de
havanes a-t-elle fumé se moque le député
socialiste guidealcour seul Jean-Luc
Mélenchon salue la sortie de la ministre
Alexandre Jardin candidat à l'élection
présidentielle oui le mouvement les
citoyens va présenter un candidat ça
sera moi